hello everyone and welcome to another
fun game from the Hanover Tournament of
1926 we said in the previous video
regarding the tournament that it was um
uh basically a celebration of the 50
years of that chess club and that they
invited some very strong players like
Aaron nimsovich and the Kiba Rubinstein
who won the tournament uh names of each
one have a point ahead of Rubenstein and
uh I said that I was gonna check out
some of the other games from the
tournament if they will be nice that I
will show them and this is one of the
games nimsovich the winner of the
tournament plays against
a very well known figure in the Chess
World back then uh even if you remember
during The capablanca Saga I mentioned
that he organized the the 1913
Tournament of San Sebastian that
capablanca won to everyone's surprise
so uh a strong player uh definitely one
of the one of the local German Masters
and he was one of the first people in
1950 to receive the actual title of
Grand Master once where they once they
came up with it uh but yeah okay let's
check out the game and it uh it features
a a line called the the nimsovich line
which is cool as arunimsovich is playing
so we have C4 names of which goes for
the English opening E5 with Knight to C3
Knight to F6 and now Knight to F3 with
Knight to C6 the Four Knights of the
English and now Ponte for the names of
each variation of the Four Knights of
the English Bishop to B4 and now Pawn to
D3 we have Pawn to D6 G3 and Bishop back
to C5 uh here Jacques wants to
re-maneuver his pieces to go after the
df2 pawn so of course Bishop G2 you have
to be ready for that Knight to G4 and it
is now as of move 7 that this move has
or rather this position has never been
repeated again and for good reasons
black doesn't really have a a a good
plan here here just castles guarding the
F2 pawn and now you really don't have
anything better than to bring the Knight
back so Knight to G4 uh not really the
best of plans but of course in those
days uh almost 100 years ago so uh this
was not known uh here Jacques went for
Ponte F5 and now Knight to D5 even
nimsovich didn't realize how bad this
move was because Bishop G5 pretty much
takes the game for white I'm just gonna
show you why Bishop G5 and now what are
you doing with the black queen okay you
could always go back Knight to F6 but
then you'll just feel silly so you're
gonna bring the queen all the way to D7
or you could bring this Knight the the
at the A7 but basically if you play
Queen here then you play e captures on
F5 now the queen has to capture the
bishop cannot capture and if Queen
captures now you play Knight to E4 and
how are you playing this with black you
can go Bishop B6 and now Pawn to H3
Knight to F6 now Knights the H4 you go
after the black queen queen E6 now
Knight captures on F6 and you completely
mess up a black spawn structure Queen to
H5 is coming you could start with Bishop
D5 attack the black queen queen E7 Queen
H5 checking to d8 and let's say 90 6 and
black resign so this is uh probably what
would happen so best would be after
Queen to D7 uh and the E captures on F5
not to go for Queen captures but rather
H6 and now maybe continue with some
Bishop to D2 and maybe black can play
this but it's just a very weird having
both F5 and H6 played so uh Bishop G5
definitely takes advantage of this early
F5 move but okay names which went for
Knight to D5 with Pawn to H6 and now
this is a really over pushing it F5 and
H6 uh just creates too many holes in
Black's camp and uh of course uh Aaron
tries to take advantage of that he
captures and F5 Bishop captures Knight
H4 with Tempo attacking the bishop also
the G6 square is being pressured with
Bishop back to E6 and now he just brings
the Knight all the way to G6 if you're
wondering why not keep the bishop on
this diagonal well the Knight is uh
hanging we're just gonna capture the
Knight so the bishop has to keep an eye
on the Knight so Bishop 6 Knight the G6
and Rook the G8 and already you can feel
that you haven't really done all that
much with black you you're not castling
King side the knights here are just
monsters and uh Aaron plays Pawn to H3
Knight F6 and now Bishop to E3 with
Bishop captures and D5 removing one of
White's attackers C captures Knight to
the D4 and now even Pawn to F4 uh we
have Queen to D7 hoping to Castle Queen
side but of course uh nimsovich will not
allow it here it comes Ponta B4
beautiful move uh as if you capture then
the Knight on D4 will be undefended for
example Bishop captures Pawn captures
spawn captures now you capture an E5 you
attack the queen and next move you win
uh the Knight with Bishop captures on D4
so after B4 the bishop has to remain on
this diagonal but still F captures an E5
D captors and Knight captures on E5
attacks the black queen queen to E7 and
now Knight to C4 uh putting pressure on
the bishop but also Defending Your or
Bishop on E3 and the problem is you
can't Castle Queen side if you Castle
Queen side then Knight captures with
check and after Pawn captures again the
Knight on D4 just hangs for free so here
King to d8 was played by Jacques sort of
prevents distacting because now if you
play Knight captures Queen captures an
E3 and ice fishing tube would win the
game for black after he captures on B6
so instead after King d8 Pawn to A4
Aaron starts pushing those Queen side
pawns Rook the E8 putting pressure on
the bishop and King to H2 as long as the
Knight defends the bishop you don't have
to worry we have Knight the E2 and now
comes Pawn to D6 here there are a lot of
other moves you could play like Pawn to
D4 you no longer have to worry about
this diagonal or you could play Queen
captures that need to just trade but a
Nims which has a different idea Pawn to
D6 he wants the weekend uh Black's uh
King's Queen side here and at some point
he will recapture on D6 with the Knight
so C captures on D6 and now Rook the E1
now he's offering a trade which of
course Jacques goes for Bishop captures
Rook captures but now he falls for
Bishop to G1 with check and the queen
will pick up the Rook but of course it
means we saw all of this queen captures
on G1 Queen captures on E2 and only now
Knight captures on D6 attacks the rook
and that B7 Pawn so Rook D7 and now Pawn
to A5 now A6 is coming so you're never
in a rush to capture and B7 we have
rooked the D7 and now Rook to E1 as The
Rook vacated the E file attacking the
queen and now Queen to D2 if you're
wondering about the D3 Pawn you can't
capture this ever
uh because Knight captures some B7 and
there is no move for black uh whatever
you do is simply insufficient like the
king to C8 you're just gonna play Queen
to C5 with check if King to B8 Rook to
C1 and there's no defense against
Checkmate so instead after rookie one
Queen to D2 was played and now we have
Knight the C4 attacking the black queen
queen capture Sun B4 uh giving up this
Pawn to advance the a pawn to Victory
Pawn to A6 now you can't capture because
the Rook would hang so here Rook the C8
was played and it's a very delicate
position where uh is of course much
better but you have to be very very
precise in order to win this so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for nimsovich while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh not rushing
it and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Rook the B1 uh if
you play a capture some B7 and then
black just gives gives back some
material Bishop captures Queen captures
and yes you are better uh but you will
have to work for your meal very very
hard instead a rook to B1 was played
which I'm sure all of you found and now
Queen to A4 and now okay now your Capron
b7a captures on B7 Rook to B8 and now
Queen to C5 brings the queen into the
attack now you have to worry about ideas
like Queen to f8 also maybe in some
lines even Queen to C8 check you might
even give up the queen so Rook the C7 a
defense uh Queen to D4 with check Knight
to D7 and now Queen captures on G7
there's no rush to Checkmate the black
king first uh uh Iron Will gobble up all
of the king side pawns Rook the C5 with
Queen to h8 check King to C7 and now
Queen captures an H6 uh not much to do
about that B7 Pawn it's sufficiently
defended so Queen to C2 attacks the rook
and now Queen to D6 with check with King
to d8 Rook to F1 now and now we have
King the E8 trying to uh be able to move
the Knight but it doesn't matter here
Rook the f8 check was played and he was
in this position on move 41 that Jacques
mises resigned in the game as there is
nothing more to be done here we're gonna
show why this loses but even faster uh
with Queen E6 check and after King The
d8 Rook F7 that's uh that was the
cleanest way to do it if Queen captures
defending Checkmate then you have Queen
E7 check and now look at this King to C7
Rook Queen characters with check King to
d8 Queen to G5 check if you go here then
Queen t7 is Checkmate so King C7 and now
Queen to A5 is a very nice Checkmate but
uh names which played Rook to f8 check
it was also enough so if you guys are
interested what would happen is is after
Knight captures The Rook is no longer
defended Queen captures King F7 uh Queen
to F or with check King Jade and now be
a queen an image which would have two
Queens on the board and of course Very
quickly and the game as there's really
no no good way to to defend this I also
have both lines work uh this is the one
uh the names of each chose uh and it was
more than enough uh so yeah I hope you
guys enjoyed that if you haven't seen
the previous video I do suggest you
check it out but just in case yes uh
names of which won the tournament half a
full Point again ahead of the The Legend
Akiba Rubenstein so I'm gonna check out
akiba's games from this tournament as
well if there's a really nice one we
will check it out as well uh so yeah
that's the game hope you enjoyed it uh
if you haven't seen the previous video
where I actually played the classical
game also do check out that one uh uh a
lot of cool cool moves were played there
uh sir I would like to thank Richard
karp uh Laurent Andre genesini revision
reptiles YouTube Kathleen Northrop and
Yoon young for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day